hello and welcome to see this to this
video what the heck am i doing and I
didn't even drink any alcohol um playing
the moss yeah I cannot pronounce that so
going to stop at Moss here what do we
get okay only know I was thinking some
kind of trash button he's it seems that
he likes to set up the start of the
Hedgehog it's not so easy to complete
the Hedgehog actually when you don't
have the the regular move water ok so
how to how to play him but I can just
grab grab more space in the center that
I don't know as long as the diagonal is
open you cannot easily fee and cata with
b6 and so on so maybe I'm still play a
couple of more moves here ok so yeah I'm
going to now take the center ok so seems
he is out for be five I cannot go if I
hear the Queen on d 2 is not so great
actually that hmm
no that was a fantastic idea probably
not okay i'm going to change this
positioning of this piece okay that
looks a little bit strange so let's
let's roll yeah b5 i currently have
under control so that it shouldn't work
with me it sometimes of course black can
just toss upon him but here i mean this
looks a little bit strange this kind of
this piece configuration here
okay so g5 is normal here but anything
else no nothing g5 yeah it seems that
like he feels like he's got all the time
here is that really the case a question
is if F Phi F is a move already or if he
can just take g5 and reply yeah i'm just
i'm shooting for this maybe you can take
g5 but this will be this will be really
dangerous okay I didn't even see that I
didn't see that hahahaha oh my god okay
the good thing is it is still dangerous
it really is still dangerous what a joke
I didn't say I didn't see the rope was a
ah great stuff
he's got his piece is somewhat clutter
too young we don't be agents on so it is
an attack it would have been a very
strong attack if I wouldn't have
blundered the whole whole board it c1
but we'll see what we can do it with
what we get here will be gotcha so going
to be as assets are going to be
dangerous without it down
yeah bishop age six is currently
currently looming and maybe f6 in some
cases
it's not an easy decision it wasn't an
easy decision for him hmm I think I have
to do this thing I need the pawn to make
g66 unavailable but I opened up my
bishop and 95 is coming it's definitely
dangerous here very dangerous so f6 and
shoot shoot fire six okay so Bishop age
6
Wow okay so so the check and 95 is good
going okay eight and this is actually
actually easier threatening to take now
in many cases yeah again the check I
guess 1 95 and 95 strong cannot take one
default item threatening Bishop g7 97
channel it wins though kingi 897 is made
and if he takes that that cannot be
survived check ok so how to do this now
look f 70 s check mate check check
Black Rose I yeah I mean talk about
lucky I completely blunder the c1 rock
there like a complete know what to call
it it was just completely moronic I
didn't didn't think I didn't see that at
all I mean f5 is still a move that the
computer likes because it gives me
fantastic compensation you anyway it's
clear that white has a somewhat
threatening position but yeah I simply
simply didn't see that this is hanging
it's funny the computer thinks that I'm
better here it's possible it's really
possible i mean the pieces that I stood
there are still on the board that I have
are very dangerous very very dangerous
yeah the computer currently is switching
between moves currently giving b5 has a
relatively best defense at the depth of
22 this is what he did and this is
already seems to lose yeah that already
loses according to the engine yeah it
gives this but here he's actually a case
even though so people will post up
talking nonsense where you cannot trust
the computer if you just let it run a
couple of seconds you need to give it
some time to see if this attack is
really coming through or not um this is
what the computer gives wants to return
a piece and here and now the valuation
is going up
well and it gives widen an edge but 0.6
orbits yeah he played this which this
looks kind of wrong on principle a
little bit just improves my position
opening up the diagonal and opening up
the d5 square here here white winsome
yeah yeah this is this was she was also
possible but I wasn't totally sure how
to win here Queenie of three is given by
the computer okay 97 is a is a very
strong thread share of course him yeah
this is even stronger than my move even
though that looks good as well but bit
surprised that the engine is ok now it
gives me when yeah it's really if you
look at the evaluation and the depth is
increasing then it goes goes higher and
higher it starts with 0.5 and at depth
23 it's a 2.4 and then must must be a
win is just too much too much attacking
power and here we already had a half the
force made check check yeah that was
also a mid check I&I department
checkmate it's also quite cute check but
Jackie I saw I saw one and delivered the
mate I still didn't see that see one was
hanging oh my okay well thanks for
watching